in other videos we have already looked
at production possibility curves and
output tables in order to calculate
opportunity costs of producing a certain
product in a certain country and then we
use that to think about comparative
advantage
we're going to do something very similar
in this video but instead of thinking
about or instead of starting with output
we're going to start with input so right
over here we have a table that shows us
the worker hours per item per country so
instead of this being an output table
where we say in a given country how much
of say toy cars can a worker in country
a produce per day here we're saying how
many hours does a worker in country a
take to produce a toy car in country a
it is two hours that labor that two
hours of labor this is the input so
we're not counting the number of cars
per day here we're saying how many hours
per car
we need to put in to produce it
similarly we have the input required in
country a to produce a belt one hour of
worker time in country b four hours of
worker time produces a toy car and in
country b three hours of worker time
produce a belt so what we're going to do
next is convert this into the world that
you might be more familiar with of
thinking in an output world and to do
that we'll just assume that there are
eight working hours
eight working hours
per day
in
either
in either country
and so from this can we construct an
output table let me put this right over
here output
output table where once again we're
going to think about the output in
country a we're going to think about the
output in country b
and this is going to be in how many
units of that product can a worker
produce per day in each of those
countries so once again we're going to
have toy cars
in this row and we're going to have
belts
belts in this row and let me just draw
some lines so it's clear that we're
dealing with a table here
so there we go
and then one more
column
and so see if you can fill these in so
how many toy cars per worker per day can
we produce in country a then think about
it for belts then think about both of
them for country b pause the video and
try to figure that out
all right now let's think about how many
toy cars per worker per day let me make
it very clear we're thinking per
worker
per
day here because if we can fill out this
output table from this i guess you could
call this an input table then we can
think about opportunity cost in the
traditional way and then we could think
about in which country do we have a
comparative advantage
so let's see toy cars in country a if it
takes two hours to produce one toy car
in country a and if you're working if
the average or if the worker is working
eight hours per day well then a worker
can produce four cars four cars times
two hours is eight hours
so
an average worker per day in country a
can produce
four
toy cars let me write that in that red
color
four toy cars i just took eight hours
and i divided by the number of hours it
takes to produce a toy car
similarly for belt if i have eight hours
and it takes an hour for a worker to
make one belt then per worker per day
eight divided by one i could produce
eight belts
and we could do the same thing for
country b and i encourage you to pause
the video if you haven't done so already
and try to fill this column out
well in country b if it takes four hours
to produce a toy car per worker that
means you take eight hours divided by
four hours that you could produce two
toy cars in a day per worker
if it takes three hours to produce a
belt well then you take your eight hours
divide it by three hours per belt and
you're going to be able to make eight
third belts per worker per day this is
the same thing as two and two third
belts per worker per day so as you can
see we can easily translate between the
input world and the output world and
then we could use this to calculate
opportunity cost so let's do that let me
write opportunity
opportunity
opportunity cost and i'll make another
table here
so
country a
country
b
and then i have the toy cars
toy cars and then i have the belts let
me do the belts in that orange color
i have the belts
and then let me set up my table
we're almost there at any point in time
pause this video and see if you can
figure out the opportunity cost given
the information that we already have we
took this table to figure out this table
and now we could take
and now we could take
and now we could take this table to
figure out this one
well let's do this together now
so toy cars what's the opportunity cost
in country a
well one way to think about it is in
country a the same energy to produce 4
four toy cars i'll call it four c c for
cars
we could also use that to produce eight
belts
so
if i were to divide both sides by four
the energy to create one car is equal to
the energy to create two belts so my
opportunity cost of a car is two belts
and if i start with this original
equation and just divide both sides by
eight i would solve for the energy for a
belt and so that would be four over
eight is one
half of the energy to make a car
is equal to the energy to make a belt
and so the opportunity cost of a belt is
half a car
one half a car and like always this and
this are reciprocals of each other and
we could do the same exercise for
country b and once again i keep
emphasizing try to pause the video if
you do this on your own as opposed to
just watching me do it it'll stick a lot
better in your brain
all right in country b the same energy
to make two
cars toy cars
with that same energy i could make eight
thirds
eight-thirds belts
eight-thirds
belts right over here so the energy to
make a car divide both sides by two is
equal to instead of one car i can make
four-thirds of a belt
and so i'll just write this as one and
one third of a belt
and then if i start right over here and
i multiply both sides by 3 8 actually
let me do that over here so i have 3 8
times 2 c is equal to 8 3 b times 3 8.
these cancel out and over here i'm going
to have 6 8 c
6 8 c is the same thing as 3 4 c is
equal to b
so instead of making one belt i could
take that same energy and make three
fourths of a toy car
three fourths of a toy car
so given everything that we've just done
which country has a comparative
advantage in toy
cars well to figure that out we just
look at the opportunity costs for toy
cars and we compare them
in country a
the opportunity cost is two belts one
country b it's only one and one third
belts so country b has the comparative
advantage right over here comparative
advantage in toy cars
and then in belts one half of a car is
less than three-fourths of a car in
belts
in
belts we see that country a
has the comparative advantage and now
what's always interesting about thinking
about this is notice country
b
has the comparative advantage in toy
cars it has less of an opportunity cost
in toy cars even though country a has
the absolute advantage its workers are
more efficient at producing toy cars a
worker can produce four cars in country
a versus two in country b but despite
that because of the opportunity cost it
would actually make sense for country b
to focus on cars and for country a to
focus on the belts but the big picture
here is we're thinking about comparative
advantage instead of thinking about it
from with an output lens from the
beginning we started with an input lens
converted that to an output lens
calculated opportunity cost and then was
able to figure out which countries had a
comparative advantage in which products